so i'm really delighted um
to introduce this event today it's part
of a kind of
sub series that we have going on at the
council of southeast asian studies here
at yale i'm the chair of the council of
southeast asian studies
and um we have a graduate student
conference
that's going on at the end of the
semester on the theme of waters and it's
organized by a group of inter asia
graduate students
um and so al lim who's here and i
were got got talking about the idea of
water
in southeast asia in particular so we
decided that we would have sort of a
side
current so to speak leading up to that
graduate student conference
al if you don't mind finding the url to
the conference you might put it in the
chat i forgot to dig it up before now
but that will um be taking place at the
end of the semester and so then we have
these
evening events um which are in addition
to our
council brownback series but these
events are all
circulating on this theme of waters
so i'm delighted today to present
or to introduce my my friend and
colleague andrew johnson
who will be talking about his new book
mekong
dreaming and rather than give an
extended introduction you know andrew
has taught at yale and u.s
at princeton i've known andrew since
graduate studies
at cornell i think his phd is from
around 2010. um
but rather than the standard
introduction i want to just read a
single sentence from this book to give
you a sense of
it um you're going to hear more about
the the the full topic of the book
but i just want to set the tone for this
evening with this sentence
how to think about such moments
when a glimpse into a higher plane
reveals a garbled
incomprehensible message let me just
read that sentence one more time
how to think about such moments when a
glimpse
into a higher plane reveals a garbled
incomprehensible message it's a really
profound
passage in a book that's full of
profound and very interesting
reflections on the art of field work
about the encounters with the
supernatural the uncanny
um the inexplicable um
and a meditation along the banks of the
mekong which is really quite a
fascinating way to get us into our
discussions
about waters in southeast asia
and to take us last week we had a talk
uh in the brownback series by jim scott
about the irrawaddy
um and so now we've moved to another
important
deltaic system and an important river in
southeast asia
but here i think what's fascinating is
we're taking it from the realm
of the material and the social to
the realm of the uncanny and how those
intersect
with the material and the social so i
won't say any more but i want to turn it
over uh
to my friend and colleague andrew
johnson um to take us on on a little
journey
uh with today's proceeding so i'm going
to mute myself and turn it over to
andrew
and he'll have a talk for you know a
kind of standard
let talk length discussion of the book
and then after that
we'll um have time for a question and
answer period and i'll moderate that
when we get to that so thank you andrew
and welcome
thanks thanks so much alan thanks thanks
eric for that uh introduction and and
thanks for everything
um thanks for inviting me here it's a
really it's a pleasure
to be speaking uh to to cease
at yale and um i'm really thrilled to be
here
uh i'd also like to introduce a friend
of mine uh vinaige
who is is uh there at the banks of the
mekong and he's gonna
show some video um of the river
where where were uh kind of what i'm
gonna be talking about and some of the
so you can kind of see in real time this
uh what's going on
there uh uh as as i talk about it
uh uh
so uh without further ado
i'll i'll start
this year the mekong river changed color
its flow was normally a muddy brown
red in local parlance but this year as
last year
the flow turned a beautiful blue it's
deep silty water became clear and those
living artists banks could see further
down than they could ima
than they could remember but no one
understood the change in the river's
quality is a good thing
fishermen could see now fish rotting on
the bottom and nets that normally hung
in slow moving eddies and the flow
became clogged with algae
and tau and lao this green mass could be
sometimes be pounded and roasted into a
sort of a laotian version of nori
but whatever advantage this newly
abundant food source had
was offset by its damage to fishing gear
nets and boat propellers became clogged
and useless
as thick green mats flowed through the
river and choked off the flow
further even for unclogged nets this
clear water presented another kind of a
problem
the kinds of nets the fishermen use
these thin filaments of blue polyester
rely on being invisible to fish in red
silty water hence the name luangmong
a trick of the eye these tricks however
don't work in clear flow
in recent years all in the mekong are
dealing with a radically different river
with different water
a different biota and different
techniques that one might use to deal
with it
but this is not limited to the area that
i'm going to be talking about today the
middle mekong in between thailand laos
uh elsewhere one of the most significant
hydrological events in the world simply
failed to manifest
as the annual backflow of the mekong
ceased now normally what would happen
is as the monsoons flow into the river
uh the river turns back on itself
flowing upstream
into the tunnel lake and filling uh
filling the lake
in the middle of cambodia which provides
most of the protein and food resources
for that country
but this year it didn't for a fisherman
this is exceptionally troubling
the mekong provides most of the protein
for cambodia and is the heart
of laos and of the issan the lao
speaking region in thailand
and fisheries have crashed in recent
years and with them entire ways of life
the reasons for all of these changes
have to do with a complicated mixture of
hydrology and geopolitics
we could think about it in this way if
you wanted to
we could think about national priorities
or economic agendas we could think about
the mekong river commission
a sort of multi-body international
organization of mekong states
that uh seeks to manage and profit from
the rivers flow
we could think about it in terms of
national developments of natural
resources shared between thailand and
laos but
resources that belong to this or to that
nation
we could think about it as a potential
political flashpoint between china and
asean
but that's not really what i do i'm an
anthropologist and that means i sort of
zoom in
to ask what these changes mean in the
lives of ordinary people
and what i want to argue here is that
the crisis in the river affects people
on multiple different levels
it's a crisis of ecology of hydrology of
economy
a family of imagination of religion
so here if uh one weakness that i think
a lot of work on on water and
and hydrology has is that it gets really
open to metaphors and so the metaphor
i'm going to use
is not quite flows and not quite streams
of consciousness as this is entitled but
a net
so relations are revealed to be
interlinked
in a mirror of the blue luangmong nets
new ecological social and spiritual
realms are interwoven
it's a core contention here that
meaningful distinctions between
the ecological the economy the economic
the spiritual
the the uh uh uh social
are not really so evident you might use
the term ontological other people have
used the term ontological to refer to a
realm that encompasses
all that exists within the world but
there's an important caveat to that idea
while all the ontological configurations
are in flux there's no
point at which there's a harmonious
stasis there's no one ontology that one
could equate with a kind of a culture or
tradition
something that lasts unchanged over time
such configurations are always changing
in a moment of ecological collapse
relations are even more in flux with
catastrophic effects and all involved
further just as we have a net that its
strands extend out into the mekong's
murky flow
the strands that make up a net often
lead beyond the
zones of apprehension a bit like that
passage that eric
uh read from the from the book we uh we
don't quite know where these strands
lead yet but still we
we hope to follow them and to harness
their potential
tim engeld has talked about these kinds
of relations
as a politics of dwelling it's a way to
rethink a binary between a sort of a
static
agent of people and a reactive passive
nature
and to kind of break apart the
assumption of fact
that the idea of nature has nature in
contrast
is not the raw conditions out there to
be perceived apprehended and sort of
utilized by an agent of person
but which we change we are changed by
this physical
being with material and biota with which
we interact
such a process of dwelling creates what
engel calls a sense of place
but here today something has gone
awry
as outside forces collapse inward upon
the mekong
and most significantly of which
hydropower and most significantly of
which chinese hydropower which i'll talk
about in a moment
this politics of dwelling becomes more
fraught
especially in recent years hydropower
projects the expansion of highly
destructive forms of fishing fishing
with bombs
fishing with agricultural pesticides or
fishing with electricity
rapid economic and ecological change and
an alteration of the local spirits of
place
have forever changed this notion of a
sense of place as we have an ingold and
who's drawing of course from heidegger
as i argue here it's not a
collapse that destroys place making
entirely but one which weaves into it
threads of obfuscation and
uncertainty anxiety the occult
so to zoom out for a moment just to
situate everybody and make sure that
we're all talking about the same river
here
the mekong is one of the largest in the
world by drainage it's the kind of the
aorta of southeast asia
it flows down from the tibetan plateau
through
series of turbulent rapids through china
then down forms the border between laos
and burma then between thailand and laos
eventually goes into the heart of
cambodia and flows out south of
saigon and vietnam it's a river split
by political boundaries and carries with
it a legacy of political conflicts
and wars but uh what you're seeing today
and i can everybody see the video
here is that um can we put
uh vinais kun vida's video on um
oh yeah okay so this part
um what you're seeing today the river
begins to flatten out after its
turbulent beginnings
stretches are still marked by rapids and
waterfalls but other reaches become
broad
sometimes this is just a result of the
time of year during the monsoon the
water level can jump up nine meters
turning what looks like a scrub forest
into a broad expanse of water
and then back down to a trickle during
the dry season
large scale alteration to the river has
come slowly at least
in comparison with many other river
systems in the world the mekong region
was not
high priority for china uh being far
from the centers of power in the middle
mekong area
has been war torn for hundreds of years
well you know american audiences might
think of the vietnam war the khmer rouge
and these kinds of things
even in the 17th and 1800s cities such
as vientiane were sacked and burned in
wars from
between siam and and laos but change has
come
and it's come very rapidly now beijing
has resolved to do something about
barriers to trade between china and
areas further downstream
and as a result they've been blasting
rapids in the river
uh trying to make the the flow navigable
by cargo ship
these alterations are happening upstream
of uh where kun finai is right now
um which itself is a little bit upstream
from vientiane
but the changes in the river are keenly
felt
specifically this has to do with
hydropower
the numbers of dams across the
mainstream of the mekong increases every
year
chinese and lao advocates argue that
these dams are necessary to produce
clean power to fuel national development
although the real beneficiaries are
likely to be those businesses involved
in exporting
the power there are 11 now in china
across the mainstream of the river
before it even flows into southeast asia
and especially the nua zaru dam
has profound impacts on water downstream
effectively
in 2019 completely stopping the pulse of
the mekong
at other times the dams release water
and
leading to unexpected gouts of water
that rush downstream
causing chaos to those living below
so in the wake of one of these floods in
2015
i followed one fisherman who i'm going
to call bong here
he and i went down the river looking for
one of the nets that had been swept away
in the flood before and as he guided us
through the
maze of rocks and islands washed clean
of uh by the recent flood we moved
through clumps of bushes with branches
there
except for a very thin line of foliage
marking the highest extent of the
recent water these are shrubs that would
ordinarily be submerged during the wet
season
then exposed during the dry season leaf
bear fruit and be submerged again
where the fish could come eat they'll
eat the fruit and then distribute the
seeds and things like this
but a rise and fall of the river in the
space of a week
as opposed to a year gives very little
time for such
processes the buds are smothered before
they even have a chance to grow and
fruit never appears
so as bong steered me through a series
of narrow channels he related to me the
multiple different fishing techniques
that he used to use just a few years ago
that no longer worked to catch catfish
the use of roadkill dog flesh pickled in
urine to catch the giant catfish's
slightly smaller carnivorous cousin
the use of a drop of opium on large
hooks for certain kinds of large fish
certain incantations and spells uh
buddhist chants
that could coax a catfish to the net a
petition to the naga a kind of a large
water dragon that i'll talk
about a little bit more today to guide
fish towards him
a specific request to the lord of the
fish a spirit that ruled over and
managed the local giant catfish
to catch one of his subjects finding a
patch of very silty
red water over in which nets could be
hung
invisible to passing fish
bong points to a failure of technique
across multiple levels
his own technologies for catching fish
no longer work
and these are technologies that are not
just material we're not just talking
about bait and nets and hooks and
traps and other kinds of things here but
this is also a reading of the water
knowing where to put the nets knowing uh
having the right kind of interpersonal
relations with nagas
with the lord of the fish with other
kinds of powers on the river
to hang his nets each of these for bong
are both
part of the same process of dwelling
each of these are interlinked
and each of these failed
so in my book here
by the way the islands this island here
that you can see
uh is the tree is no longer there but
it's the one
right behind uh
uh
anyway you can see how the island has
changed so over the years
in the book i look at the sense of loss
and trace the links between hydropower
and what we might call dwelling on the
mekong
charting the multiple factors that
influence how one lives with the change
river
as i mentioned bong's fishing involves
him knowing what particular fish
would be active what material bait would
draw the fish to him
what traps to set for the fish but also
access to accessing some further
means to ensure that the fish actually
comes something from realm so we might
call
magical or religious and which i'm just
going to call potential
we can think of it continuing at this
metaphor of the net
as using those lines that are partially
or wholly obscured within the water
and that which we need we need new
techniques to perceive
indeed while bong described techniques
that no longer work he also described
new ones that did
the recently arrived medium of a naga
one who conducted spirit medium in a
very different style from the
traditional laotian style
spirit mediums along the the river uh
but rather dressed in a central thai
style wore
all the all white of an aesthetic were
heavy wooden prayer beads
indeed this medium had answered his
request one year
and sent him two giant catfish just the
day before he was
supposed to entertain high-ranking
guests
so in the book i look at the material
qualities of the mekong land and
waterscape
including its temporality the water
itself fish
and the changing techniques used to
access them and i go over these briefly
today
in the book i go into more detail if
you're interested in other things i i
go into more detail about migrant labor
borders the productive potential of
foreign actors including spirits
to play into this change this in turn
involves mekong concepts of time
as time and space become vital to how
potential fish become
actual fish and ultimately speaks
towards dwelling
in uncertain times
the mekong itself is in constant motion
in three directions
its flow is hypnotic it normally flows
from west to east until the monsoons
engorge it and of course down in
cambodia then it switches back to flow
east to west um it flows
up and down too whirlpools the size of a
fist form on the surface with great
sucking sounds travel a few meters
downstream
and then dissipate plateaus of water
bubble up from underneath
these are expected when the water flows
over a great rock
but many are unpredictable they form
seemingly out of nowhere
and disappear into the swirl there's an
endless
churn in the red brown flow for
fishermen the water is a constant topic
of conversation
it can be little noi or much fly
it runs either red with sediment or
clear meaning with a visibility of a few
inches now clear has come to take a
whole different meaning
at nights of the full moon those living
on its banks report fireballs erupting
from its steps
at which they attribute to nagas living
within the river
the topography of the river is mediated
by its rapid
those rocks over under and around which
the water flows
one navigates by reference to this or
that rapid gang
which have names or stories some like
the great gangpan
have personalities and this ladder rock
despite its reputation which
the name means cruel rapid guard some of
the best fishing in the area
a decade ago the rapid tore the bottom
out of a chinese cargo vessel attempting
to go over it and cargo and oil floated
downstream
for days sometimes a rock is more than
sometimes a gang a rapid is more than
just a rock
a pocket of sand might grow into a beach
when the water drops
sometimes larger plants might colonize
it and create an island
and a rounded island it might make a
long
lazy swirl a place that's really good
for fishing with a throw net
or a place to fence off a part of the
river to store live fish
in my field site too there's a deep pool
called called nong which is usually a
word that's used for an uh fresh water
inland
uh sorry in a place away from the river
kind of a a spring-fed pool
here's where the water persists in the
dry season when the rest of the river
drops down to a trickle
or when the water remains relatively
still in the wet season
when the gang are raging here too is
where the
mekong giant catfish live this is a fish
that can get up to several hundred
kilograms
about the size of a small cow and from
where the divine king the lord of the
fish rules
a shrine to the lord stood stands just
next to the village center above the
swirling pool
the village traces its roots to the pool
from a laotian group from the former
royal capital of long pabang
they at some unspecified point in time
in the past centuries
traveled down the mekong river until
they came here and gazing down
into the still clear water they could
see the forms of giant catfish swimming
in the water and decided that this place
was the dwelling of the lord of the fish
in the 1930s this village entertained
the lord of vientiane each year
who resided over the festivals calling
in the lord of the fish to possess the
body of a medium and declare that
catches of catfish would be plentiful
that year so long as everybody's
morality had been
upstanding so the pool which had
formerly been off limits owing to its
sacred status
is now a fishing site in recent years
since the fishing has cratered out
and that's still hanging in the water
today
my point in going over these these
different words and sort of description
of the river itself
means is that in the topography of the
river makes it a nest
of distinct places these are places that
change depending on the time of year
and house a variety of other than human
beings and human activities
these create a social map marking off
space
space that varies for the level of the
water but the division in the river
into distinct places also delineates a
political system of property ownership
revealing a legal grid that overlays the
sort of hydrological
grid and the ecological grid of the
river according to a mutual agreement of
village heads from either side of the
river
certain places are designated as public
or private
determining who has the right to fish
where these locations are
also affixed to a particular feature
there's this eddie or that rapid or
something like this
the richest fishermen might own the
rights to fish at several sites
and fishing plots can be bought sold
inherited least just like land property
could too
a good fishing site could go for several
tens of thousands about before the dams
came in
about three hundred to one thousand
dollars and if you didn't have one
you could still throw a fish with a
throw net in a public edie
or you could stand on the edge of a
boulder and try your luck with a
precarious uh
dip net so my point here is to say
fishing in the river is bound within a
net of relations that cross
uh international borders in excess and
outside of a legal right to a particular
zones in the river
and it's tied in with this hydrological
features there's public zones with the
particular rules
private plots with their own system of
tenure and until recently sacred spots
for their own particular spirits
associated with them
but these fishing sites
are in the middle of an international
boundary lao fishermen claim the megong
up to the point right to the
thai shore and suggests that they are
simply being generous neighbors
in allowing thai nationals such as bong
upon its waters and allowing the system
of lung mong to persist
but this is ignored by all involved bong
and others cross this line regularly on
their boats without any kind of
paperwork
when i press bong on the competing legal
definitions of what constitutes lao or
thai places the water he simply
responded
it doesn't the nations aren't applicable
here
so the hydrology of the river enables
claims to plots of water that are
recognized by no
authority higher than the village had
meant in his lao neighbor
these two authorities agree on who owns
what fishing site at what time and are
responsible for adjudicating disputes
over them
here too the police certainly can't uh
do not and cannot get involved
a thai policeman would have questionable
authority over property rights claimed
by another country
not to mention midstream in this sort of
grey zoom
however as i explore in the book such
conflicts do indeed erupt with laotian
police thai military thai police and
village heads
each pulling in their own different
separate directions
so these system of property ownership
and fishing rights constitute another
way of seeing ownership and authority in
the river
tied to place a way of seeing the river
as shared space that has nothing to do
with bangkok or vnt and much less to do
with beijing
and cross river authority as ruled more
by force of personality
than legal mandate but
with changes in the water become come
multiple changes at the level of
authority as well
rapids if not blasted can become
submerged in a flood
or turn into full-fledged islands in
an ebb and the fisheries these fisheries
have been some of the hardest hit
by recent hydropower projects when
floods rip through the village the most
common casualty are those nets strung
within the fishing grounds
the nets already become prone to
tangling become a pale blue mess
as they are torn from the eddies in
which they float most often they end up
in the morning after the flood stranded
on top of a boulder
with fish too ensnared to be removed
rotting in the sun
and of these most are swept away and too
damaged to be recovered this is
the the most of the the financial damage
from a flood
thus of the sites that uh fong pointed
out to me
many if not most were devoid of nets
here either nets have been swept away or
equally as often
bong described the owners as waiting
before they they attempted any more
fishing
some had lost nets and were waiting for
the money to kind of replace them and
put them back
in others were waiting for the algae
bloom to subside but some were simply
waiting for the instability in the river
to be over
prices for fishing plots in the entire
system of mutual ownership went into
freefall
and recrimination sometimes village
against village sometimes loud against
tie and sometimes simply interpersonal
flared even turning violent some
abandoning fishing altogether turn
towards fishing with electric charges or
bombs
and the thai police inspector of the
docks in turn began patrolling laotian
waters armed
and uh drunk at times firing at those he
thought were fishing using these
destructive techniques
fishing and by the extension the realm
managed by local authority is changing
the new landscape of potential is
uncertain and only after this new world
emerges
can decisions be made
so i've talked a little bit about uh
i'm gonna move forward just a little bit
i talked a little bit about the the
change in the pulse in the yearly pulse
of the river and what i want to focus on
is how this pulse marks time
and um in that as people decide when to
lay the nets and when to use what
particular techniques they do so based
upon a series of
of buddhist festivals which are then
linked to the waters
flood and its retreat this also involves
planting crops along the riverbank as
the water dies down
the it leaves a thick silty deposit
which is really good for planting
particular kinds of crop
now where the water rises and falls with
um against
natural cycles this becomes impossible
to protect
so the new mekong has a different time
from the old one
and with it what was once efficacious is
no longer if we were to
reframe this statement in sort of
theoretical terms the mekong becoming
damned opens onto a new uncertain field
of potentiality
and these rhythms of course uh originate
when the chinese controller of the dam
decides to retain or release water
decisions that are on principle not
communicated downstream without the
communicate
to without the ability to communicate
with the chinese dam fishermen can only
watch the water level for indication
that the dam controller has acted they
know very well the cause of the floods
but not whether or not one is coming and
when it will
these are also changes to popular
buddhist practice during the height of
the dry season
normally sandy islands rise up out of
the water as the water falls
and on these islands villages from the
lao side and the thai side come together
and make it kind of a festival village
where you can race tractors
and drink beer and kind of engage in all
the profits that
low water fishing has but in 2015
a glot of water came through and wiped
out the village
causing tens of thousands about worth of
damage
and entirely disrupting the whole cycle
of the whole
process of celebrations for the new year
so patterns of rise and fall are one
stranded in the way that one marks
time in the mekong a yearly cyclical
calendar punctuated by buddhist holidays
fishing and farming practices
in the monsoon the dry season when you
build festival villages and sandy
islands emerge from the flow coincides
with an abundance of fish
and large fish are easy to catch in low
water these in turn fuel temple
donations
sacrifices to river beings and social
events and ritual activity centered upon
mobilizing villager's own potency
and around this time uh if anybody of
you have been to issan no
there's a rocket festival where large
very phallic rockets are fired up into
the sky
triggering the monsoon so in this way
rituals kind of gain the power to yield
rain
when the water is near its height in
converse other beings in turn act
this is the time when people see naga
fireballs as nagas come up
and spit their own fire into the sky
then causing the clouds to disperse
and the water to drop so land beings act
to break about the rise of the water
river beings act to bring about its ebb
the water the base calendar
the mekong mobilizes the potency of
particular technologies
so the dam then alters time along the
mekong
monsoon time and buddhist time become
disrupted via new modes of time
when the gates open when they shut in
the wake of the dam
the river and those within it become
disentangled from the rhythms
the mekong water level is no longer
linked to the rain which in turn is
de-linked to the
ritual activity meant to provoke rain
fish follow suit and as the naga show
so do river beings so now in the wake of
the new mekong this situated knowledge
fails and new practices arise
moratoriums on fishing in particular
seasons and in particular sites have
elapsed
and in response to falling yield
fishermen to compensate for the lack of
knowledge of how to handle this new
river
turn towards other fishing techniques
as fishermen no longer trap fish with
old methods and as naga fireballs while
they still appear
do not bring about a lowering of the
water and as high water comes with or
without phallic rockets
river time is becomes disentangled
disentangled from buddhist time
monsoon time calendric time events that
will previously simultaneous
are not any longer so now is a different
time in which to dwell for people
for fish and for spirits as well
so as the story of the lord of the fish
and the naga indicate the disappearance
of fish is not just about economy
rather it prevent presents a fundamental
religious problem as well
sources of invisible potential on the
river are not what they once were
shrines to the naga thought to exist
within the water were at times
declared to be shrines to dead naga
where the spirits lived on even after
the physical great serpents died owing
to the river's
change as uh as one fisherman told me
nagas used to come out of the river they
would come into town put on human
clothing
and come to the temple to listen to the
buddhist chanting sometimes they would
even marry women from the village
and then they stopped so i asked him
they pressed him a little bit further
well why did they stop
and he responded quite simply they got
tired of us
elsewhere other river beings underwent
similar transformation
a lao style medium a very similar sort
of religious professional who featured
on the in the the right surrounding the
the giant catfish 100 years ago
was the voice of an island king a spirit
that looked after the village and sent
catches of fish to villagers nets but
found herself openly mocked after a 2015
possession ritual whereas a new male
bangkok style medium who lived an
ascetic's life in a cat
in a cave behind the temple gained
adherence
old orders based around river and fish
slip away to be
replaced by the representative of a new
order and a new flow
uh significantly here the flows of
international migrant labor
the struggle to get a good work contract
and to flow kind of outwards from the
village
so the removal of religious figures from
the physical realm including the realm
of kinship
and participation in communal religious
activity also suggests a shift in
notions of materiality
the physical naga becomes a ghostly one
but a ghost that points not to the
uncanny and not to haunting
but to the presence of new promises and
new possibilities even as
another way being declines it's a shift
that occurs as the workings of
neoliberal capitalism multiply
as rubber prices rise and fall as
migrant labor becomes more tenuous and
as the political future of the northeast
becomes more in doubt
but more than this the natural world
itself has changed
as the formerly predictable mekong full
of beings with which one had a kind of
particular relationship becomes a new
kind of a place
but even as all that is solid seems to
melt into air it does not disappear
as established economic and
environmental orders fail and new
miraculous or catastrophic
horizons of possibility open up new
cosmological worlds are born
so through a micro examination of the
impacts of chinese hydropower in one
small fishing community
i want to show the scale of such changes
the collapse of the mekong under new
hydropower projects creates alterations
that can escape notice
if we only think about the mekong as a
confluence of national interests
bangkok beijing and vientiane might very
well benefit from
the alterations taking place in the
river thailand bests national interest
in the capital
in bangkok not necessarily in issan and
mekong regions
and laos has one of its national
priorities to become the battery of asia
but for many that i discuss here such
changes
involve multiple scales including highly
personal ones
the hydrology the river changes it's
color it's movement
even the way one marks space on the
river changes this is a very intimate
alteration ways of marking both
space and time ways of dividing
territory and dividing time are lost
ways of relating to other inhabitants of
the river fish and spirits
disappeared rare to be replaced by as i
described further elsewhere
new hybrids new spirits new sources of
power
new sources of potential ones that are
more uncertain and ones that are more
fraud
in short as infrastructure itself alters
the way the world works
new sources of potential prosperous as
well as disastrous
become revealed that's all i have for my
talk
right now i would like i i would if i
could ask
um like to show a little bit more of the
river as it is
[Music]
so if you can all see this is this is
the stretch of river that i'm that i'm
talking about there
you've got areas of the bank that have
been fortified
by concrete over there is an island that
i
feature on the cover of the book but
that tree is now gone
um and
anyway that's that's looking across the
border into laos
right there
can people see now there was just a shot
where you
you see the same sun rising over there
but at a different time of day
oh yeah this is probably at about 5 a.m
or something like that
i think right now this is now about 9.
so with that um be happy to take
questions or start discussion
or um
great thank you thank you andrew um so
uh i just want to take a moment and give
him some applause for a wonderful talk
so thank you um now we're going to shift
to the question and answer period
and i will field the questions um so if
you have a question
um you can either use the hand raise
function on zoom if you know how to use
that
um if not you can send a note to the
chat um to say that you have a question
or even put it
in there or raise your hand wildly and
i'll try and catch you
in the video or something like that i
see that paul sarno has the first
question so go ahead paul
thank you for that wonderful talk um
i think you said that there are 11 dams
in china that affect mekong
are there dams in laos that affect the
macon
and how absolutely absolutely there
there's um
this number is is constantly changing
and so in terms of
dams across the mainstream side there's
one
not too far upstream here that's a bit a
massive hydropower project
that has that extends just across the
mainstream of the river
now it's not a very deep dam it's not a
high reservoir dam
um so the changes that it that it it
engenders are not uh it's not a a
flood you know massive drying and
massive flood however
um this clarity of the water
the algae bloom and the clarity of the
water that sort of
taking the silt out of the water
occurred after the cyber was
was built so it still holds back a good
deal of water and it's really
responsible for a lot of the changes in
the quality of the water
um however during during my field work
the chinese dams being a kind of a
higher reservoir
uh dams are are have a different kind of
an impact so there's multiple different
ones
now elsewhere in laos there's other
proposed names including one
just uh you know 20 minutes drive away
from
from this spot right here um quite close
by and there's an
uh vast number of dams on tributaries
that come in including one just by luang
pabang as well
uh there's a a quick question uh are the
rocks in the in the background natural
or man-made
i think you can see one area where the
village has decided to
shore up the banks with concrete rocks
that was a response to the dams in fact
because
this irregular flow was
not allowing the stilt to fortify the
banks themselves
you didn't get a nice kind of sandy
slope on the side of the
the river and instead you had a constant
flow that
ate away at the bank and you had a lot
of collapse so what
what the the village government did is
they came and they they fortified it
with those rocks that you see right
there
i think that's the extent of them they
they stop up there and then they go back
to the the village center
and a little ways down if just beyond
that if you could see in the distance
there wouldn't be any rocks like that
now there are big boulders elsewhere
that i don't think are in frame here
um which are natural but those
particular ones that kind of
guarded by a wire mesh are man-made
sorry i muted myself um
thank you uh for that question and for
for the great um
reply andrew um we have a question from
tweedo
um uh tui do you want to answer
ask your question now
um yes i'm not from lao i'm from vietnam
but
i live in in the american delta in
vietnam for
like seven years and i worked closely
with the farmers
so i see like during the flood season
like
during the first season i don't know how
and as usual correctly so during the
first seasons
like the the the delta looks like it's
like
full of water it look beautiful
when i'm not from there originally i'm
from the southeast of
vietnam so when i went there we lived
there and i see it's beautiful
but then now they they build the dye the
anti-fluff dye
that professor james scott last week
some weeks ago
she said it's an engineer flush
something they build at them to
anti-flood
and it it it like it
changed the flow of the rivers
so it's damaged it's actually damaged
like
the the farms the rice farms
in in the medical delta in vietnam like
we
the end we are the end of the
of the american so the the influence of
the mecca is
significant like when the chinese debut
the time so
the the the fridge not going down to the
the making the
investor in vietnam anymore but i'm not
sure
so we didn't now we're not talking about
fishing
because it's we cannot do anything with
that
so now we we raise fish a lot we don't
have natural fish
from the from the from the river but i'm
not sure in laos
like we now we talked about how to
prevent the influence of the dam
far from through events of the land to
the
to the right harm like the nutrition of
the river is
actually like during the flow season it
bring nutrition to the farms
now it's not anymore so is it like the
same
influence in thousand and individuals
like you see anything and then what the
laos government
do with that doing with that we do at
last but
it's not actually do it and this
there's a lot to that to that question
and i think um
yes it's the same process absolutely
because the the silt that that gets
you know when the river comes in and it
floods and it carries with it all the
silt if that
if that gets trapped behind a dam i mean
first off if you trap all the silt
behind a dam it decreases the efficiency
of the dam right because it clogs
everything up and eventually
over a short period of time the dam
stops producing uh
power in the way that it did when you
first built it so you trap all that silt
back there
but so that's one reason why the silt
doesn't get carried downstream doesn't
get deposited in the delta
and doesn't create fertilizer for for
rice farms also with less flow
uh in vietnam the problem is you have
less flow so salt water creeps in
and so you get uh problem salt getting
into rice fields too which is a
tremendous issue and
that also makes has economic effects too
in that
uh shrimp farms get more and more
common and more and more profitable uh
which are
require a lot more equipment and are
owned by wealthier
people and so you get sort of a class
economic problem there too
but in in terms of of what's going on
allows certainly
um the lack of of stilt and then efforts
like those
like those rocks that you saw that
protects the banks from collapsing but
it also
speeds the water on its way and blasting
rapids as china has done further
upstream also speeds the water on its
way too
so with you faster moving water with
less silt in it
the water then picks up less silk
because it's not it's not really able to
deposit that
and so any silt that it has gets jetted
out into the
into the sea and doesn't really get
deposited so it's a it's an entire
change in the way the river goes
and vietnam being at the very end of of
the the system
gets a lot of the effects a lot of the
downstream effects
i see a question on um
uh from uh from from carol and and
from pat uh that i i'd like to ask um
um
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
yeah so towards the end of the year
there's there there is uh
they had snake boat racing and yeah
toward the end of the year they've got
they do have uh
competitions of snake boat racing just
uh not something that i've done
there but um but yes that was the
question and
and uh yes
um in your field research you get a
sense of how children are impacted it's
a new ebb and flow of the make-on impact
of space for kids or what kids
can do with their time in that space um
yeah there there's the river is always a
place that
that you know in the afternoon that kids
play they
they that this is a place of recreation
as well as a place
of of of work of activity too so sure
and it's
changing the river i'm not sure of so
much of that or of other kinds of things
migrant labor is still a certain uh
increasing in importance as fishing
decreases in profit and migrant labor
kind of gets more and more important
and so having a parent abroad is
certainly an impact on the lives of
children
there so in terms of the change in the
water maybe not so much but the larger
social change that a change in the river
engenders
definitely has massive impacts upon the
lives of kids definitely
sure andrew
i i want to ask you a question about
time
yeah um and
the thing that i note about your book is
that it it
operates at a very kind of almost
metaphysical level i don't know if
that's the right word to use
actually but it's in your talk here
in some sense you were more pragmatic
than the book the book
takes us into a kind of philosophical
registers about existence a little bit
right
and so i wanted to pose a question about
time because you brought it up
in in the talk here about the kind of
meeting of different
time experiences not just time as watch
time but
a kind of cosmological time the time
experience of the river and then
how um physical transformation of the
river
is actually transforming the experience
of time and temporality right so
um you talked about space on one hand
obviously
if you flood a river or you drain a
river
the shape and look and form of it will
be different and so it will change the
spatiality that people have to it right
but the time was also so fascinating and
what i wanted to ask you about
was this idea of the naga having a
certain kind of
temporality right but at the same time
sorry for the word at the same time but
um at the same time
that people are reflecting on
naga time they're also very easily able
to say well once there was
the naga doing x y and z and now there's
not
right so there's a kind of linearity a
before and after that's
pretty straightforward on one level you
know like we used to do this
now we don't do we don't do that anymore
there was when the dam
came everything changed right and so my
question to you
is there really like a kind of
metaphysical or you could say
ontological whatever
word is appropriate um difference about
time along the river um
or is it really just a variation of a
kind of universal temporality
and and what are your thoughts on that
and maybe we can't really
decide it right now but what are some of
the ways in which you've thought about
that
problem and just i'll add to it because
even
as we see your friend when they're um
i almost feel a visceral difference of
temporality
because i remember my own times along
rivers right when you're at a river you
have a different kind of engagement
with with space time somehow right and
so how do we deal with that
like layered to the real time of history
not real time but
the temporality of history and then the
temporality of an
alternative temporality along a river
i mean time is in perception right so
time time depends upon your apprehension
of time and your
your experience of time and and yeah
multiple different registers and i think
one i start off the book in talking
about um
the messianic and apocalyptic time time
experiences so
when people talked about the dams a lot
of times i start off
with a dream that what um uh one of my
interlocutors had
about the damn breaking and he he dreamt
that he saw
a a a gap in the dam and it was going to
one day crack in half and flood and
destroy the entire town
and so that also that place is a
particular marker in the future of what
happens when these
what happens when these things fail or
what happens when they succeed
too much what happens when we can no
longer wait um
so there's this future point and then of
course as you're saying there's a sort
of a past point too
that like before before the dam came it
was like this
and there's also i think this feeds into
there's a number of different registers
that this feeds into
one is the kind of cult of development
that is sort of
endemic many many places in the world
maybe every place in the world but this
idea that like
that things continually progress along a
certain kind of a linear path
towards more complexity or more
development or we get a
i remember the year when we got
electricity i remember the year when the
um
where the road got paved i remember the
year these kinds of markers there
and so that projects in the future a
kind of an upward trajectory
that can then be casted a doubt by
by intimations that hey there might be
disaster actually at the end of this
and so there are these points um in
various points in history and especially
nissan
um where you get this notion of
messianic time comes in there's a uh
what is it
a millennial millenario group
that not the millennials there there's
something they're also apocalyptic but
there's something else
um but there's there's a movement in the
early 2000s or the early 19th early 20th
century
that was positing there there would come
a sort of a time when everything would
change its shape
so animals would become demons money
would become
excrements and the only thing solid in
the world would be lemongrass since you
would have to hold on to stalks of
lemongrass don't keep from being blown
away by a giant wind that would sweep
through the land
um also there was the communist movement
which was
tremendously you know based in the
province just
very very close to this area in which
you know people in in
this village and others up and down the
mekong had complicated relationships
with
uh so and and of course communism there
he also posited a time
a time free of imperialism a time of
revolution
the kind of constant revolution so this
constant deferment
of disaster and hope off in the future
marks another point at which
there's a future point there's a pass
point at which things were
mythical mystical the naga was still
alive and there you are caught somehow
between these two points as you're
waiting
sort of for something to happen in
between these two the future point the
past point
you're caught um
and i think yeah there is a certain
about the actual
you know gasoline bachelorette or
something like this but
talk about the the time as that's the
material that the time that's embedded
within the material of the river
that also has its own particular rhythms
and its own particular
cycles beyond just the the pulse of the
mekong
but you know the way that time passes in
a particular day there's
boats that come at night which are the
fish shockers or maybe people
running meth from across the border
which happens
um something untoward happening in the
middle of the night or maybe it's just
your friends coming back from
uh illicit pub in laos um you know
really late
then the chanting starts up around four
or five in the morning and then the
the animals start and then the traffic
starts and the morning boats start so
there's a whole
a whole auditory sensory perception that
that
informs you in a very bodily way about
the passage of the time that is always
connected to the river that's always
linked
to that feeling of listening to what the
river is doing or what people are doing
on top of the river
informs you of your sense of time of
your sense of of the passage of time
so between like the yeah the
metaphysical the the the
apocalyptic messianic potentials in the
future
and then the kind of experience of of
everyday passage
of time too i i find i found time
temporality and time and there's debates
laura bears got these debates about you
know
we should really be saying time and not
temporality but the
this notion of the uh affective passage
of time
is something that i really um it's
always very striking
i think thank you
um we have a question from hal go ahead
al
yeah so kind of related to this um
something i took away from the book was
this idea of ambivalence or the
productive potential of maybe um so you
talk at
in the opening vignette about how
there's a sense of ambivalence and and
that
to me was really interesting just just
taking seriously that kind of
ambivalence with
what's a what we call a ontological
alternative so i thought that was super
interesting but
i'm wondering how you can how you
reconcile that with a kind of
a kind of anthropology that's emerging
in terms of practices like people who
want to know who's complicit
and kind of like who are the
stakeholders at work and kind of
um a kind of politics of accountability
so how do you
juggle the kind of ambivalence and and
accountability um
one one is asking for kind of like
taking seriously that murkiness but the
other is kind of
murky but people want to shine a light
on it how do you how do you position
yourself
between these kind of um holes in a
sense
that's a good question and that's also
something that i that i think about a
lot
and you know i'd like to say i i do both
right and and that's like the right
answer but um
so explain why i do both i mean first
off
i i have some very practical and and
pragmatic
um uh alliances that that i think i um
in in in the town where i work in that
region there's a number of ngos
that that i um you know i
meet up with when i'm down there and and
sort of very practical
making sure that what i do doesn't
damage
the the site where i work and in fact
you know i'm able to
to
[Music]
help along the interests of the people
with whom i work as much as i can on the
other hand
too i mean i'm personally coming from a
very sort of deconstructive kind of
anthropology where i think it's in
reflexive
i think it's always vital to question
your own assumptions
when you're coming into a uh a fieldwork
situation
so questioning the stakeholders saying
okay
can we really chart out the right you
know
ethic the ethically right position the
politically right position to take
and then identify the stakeholders
involved i think uh marisol de la cadena
uh
talks a little bit about this and and
incorporating like non-human
stakeholders within the
thing within within your sort of um
uh pluriverse as she says within your
your political unit
um that's good
that's i think that speaks towards
taking other ways of seeing the world
seriously
but on the uh in addition to that i
think
we also need to recognize and this is
really important to me we need to see
the the other than human the non-human
as uh as
our interlocutors see it or as and and
not
as like their culture or their ontology
or something like that but we we are all
in a way questioning
and myself included questioning what
exists in the world
and having real debates about what
exists in the world i remember having a
a talk with with um
another friend of mine from from the
same
region and um a friend of mine knew we
had been friends since 2014 or something
like this and he asked me you know do
you
uh do you believe in ghosts
and this is something that you know i
get a lot i write i write a lot about
ghosts and i'm very used to this
question and so
i
which is the standard thing you're
supposed to say and he got angry with me
and he said look i asked you a question
i'm asking you sincerely
um and i realized that i've been using
that
as a way of saying okay so this is what
i'm interested in what you believe and
and
in your ideas and now i'm i'm
standing on my other side of my
anthropologist's side i'm going to write
this down i'm going to say okay so this
is thai
you know metaphysical reality
ontological reality whatever you want to
say
no i wasn't being taken as that i was
being taken as a co-investigator in the
world
and so what he said is he says you know
you've been around of many places
you are you've studied a lot you know
you must know
something so what do you know and let's
let's compare
and i realized that he's asking to be
taken seriously as
a co-investigator of the world and that
i think as an anthropologist it's very
important for us
to do that to recognize that
our interlocutors are collaborators and
not eat not just in the sense of like
oh we're going to get together and you
know maybe try to
give photo credit or co-author or
something or or
or co-present something but it
co-investigators into
the kinds of questions we're asking
nobody has a distinct answer so who are
the stakeholders
is the naga stakeholder i don't know
nobody knows um and i i think answering
that honestly
is is is one way of of getting a being
sort of
getting true to the heart of what the
ethnography means to destabilize your
own sense of surety about what exists
and when how the world works
which is what i think the point of
anthropology is so
let's step back
co-researcher yeah yeah yeah that that's
paul
before i before i let you ask your
question i wanted to say one little
thing
i wrote that word co-researcher because
um
when you were speaking about um
co-investigator
um andrew i it reminded me of
a misreading that may be actually
interesting
because when i read your book you used
the term in i think in the introduction
somewhere i can't remember what page
but the word co-researcher which i just
wrote in the chat for everyone
but when i when i first read the word
and this is
honest truth i thought i'd never seen
that word
written like that before and i thought
that it meant core searcher
that's and and and the story that you're
telling
and then i said oh actually he means
co-researcher but then i remember
pausing thinking
well actually what he's saying is that
we're all
in this together as searching for the
core right which is sort of what the
story you just described
with your your friend there he's like no
we're co we're not just co-investigate
we're core searchers
and we're doing it together looking for
the core of human existence or something
like that you know or something and so i
just wanted to
do that play on words that was
unintentional but i know that paul
has a question but you can respond to
that real quick if you want
um paul and then then i'll get to
william's question here
i i was curious i i had the feeling that
perhaps these fishermen and farmers on
the thai
side must be complaining at least to the
regional thai government if not the
central government
about what's happening what does the
central
government or the regional government
say to them and i had the same question
i don't know if you know
what the lao fishermen and farmers are
saying
that that's my answer to that question
would have been different two years ago
and um i think
as a side anecdote there was one um
uh possession ritual sort of a
spirit medium ritual that i was involved
in where
the the people were asking the spirit
medium to kind of stop the dams and
get the spirits to stop the dams and the
spirit calls up the the laotian spirit
on the
on on the phone on the you know uh
and to ask to request a stopped to the
damn and then what the lawsuit spirit
says is
this is what is necessary for national
development and i think that would be
the answer that you would get from
the lao government as well as the lao
spirit
lord too and i i think that's no
accident that the two are speaking in
the same voice
on the thai side now the a lot of the
electricity in bangkok
i'm sure many of you have spent time
there you have
shopping malls that consume as much
individual shopping malls
that consume as much electricity as an
entire province
the province of mihongsan is
uses half as much electricity as the
shopping mall of siam paragon
so thailand has always been a
center-oriented
state where resources are pulled to the
center they're
part of the pushback against the regime
of tuxen was
was a pushback against this sort of
distribution of wealth a little bit
outside of the center even though
it was going to his own projects but the
the
drawing in of of resources to the center
uh has meant that the lives of of people
on the outskirts
don't get much play however recently
this year even i think
uh thailand has formally complained to
the lao government and has intimated
that it will not purchase electricity
from
uh some of the new dams sayabari that
has
it's purchasing from but there are some
of the new dams there
the tigerman has said it's not going to
i don't know why i don't know what's
behind that it may be
good intentions it may be honorable
intentions i
don't trust it but maybe
um but there is an act
oh sorry is most of the electricity
being sold to thailand or to china
to tie the the electricity generated in
laos is going to to
thailand uh further upstream some of
that may go to china
but it's even the chinese dam's right on
the border that's coming that's being
that's that's being sold for capital
um so william asks i'm speaking of
co-research are you engaged in or
thinking of engaging in multi-sided and
extended project that incorporates other
anthropologists working both up and down
stream in china cambodia and vietnam
um william are you in charge of a large
grant making
projects um we could answer our
our own questions here not yet sad face
okay well let me know when you are
and and what's all um but i think it
practically speaking i would love to
i would actually love to get involved
with um
a fishery scientist too because the the
the actual
there has not been a lot of good fishery
studies
in the area in in on the mekong river
further down in cambodia there have been
some but the middle mekong region
and especially as you go further up into
laos and china
the barriers to doing environmental
field work are
increased laos famously
some years ago uh environmental
activists disappeared and
you know presumably
make it interdisciplinary and add a
geographer sure
um yes now let's let's find grants
everyone
i think you've see with it with our
modest uh
evening right here we've created a make
on studies uh
coalition i mean so i hope all of you
can be in touch with each other
but it's quite clear that the the work
is important
um i i want to bring it to a close right
now it's
with our evening um discussions i try
not to go too late just to make
sure that we all don't get exhausted um
but if there's
uh if anyone has a final question
they're really dying to ask we can do
that right now
otherwise um we'll turn off their
recorder and and
um uh and bring the session to a close
um
let me just see if there's any further
question
and i do hope that folks will um turn in
uh too sorry tune in uh to to some of
the upcoming events both in our
southeast asia council brownback series
um and in our side eddie series on
waters here
i will i will draw your attention in
particular to our talk in the brown bag
next week will be uh vince rafael who
will be giving a a very provocatively
titled talk called duterte's phallus
uh i don't have the full subtitle but
aesthetics of vulgarity
in duterte's philippines um so i think
it'll be quite a great um
experience and i hope some of you can
join us for that those talks are on
wednesdays at noon
um and then there's a few other series
in the in the water series and then at
the
end of the academic semester there's the
big graduate student
conference and so i hope you can all
tune in to some of these other events
thanks everyone